on perd un nouveau type d'escroqueries
via internet arrive en france il s'agit
du phishing à nom qui nous vient des
états unis
une fraude qui consiste à subtiliser les
informations bancaires pour détourner de
l'argent en imitant un mail provenant de
votre banque explications paul de genève
josé boulesteix vous avez l'habitude de
gérer vos comptes par internet
méfiez-vous cet e-mail pourrait provenir
de votre banque sous prétexte de
problèmes de sécurité elle vous demande
de vous rendre sur son site
s'ouvre alors une page avec un
questionnaire numéro de compte numéro de
carte de crédit
les informations les plus
confidentielles vous sont demandées mais
c'est un piège ces informations sont en
fait enregistré par une personne
malveillante qui va réutiliser celle ci
pour vider votre compte en banque pour
effectuer des virements vers des comptes
extérieurs et ainsi vous berner cette
nouvelle escroquerie ce après le
phishing ou hameçonnage des banques
françaises sont déjà touchés les
enquêtes sont en cours
le principe est simple l'escroc envoie
des millions d'e-mails qui imitent ceux
d'une banque connu quelques internautes
mordent à l'hameçon et transmettre leurs
données au début de l'année on pouvait
recenser près de 1800 sites
actif dans le monde et pour la france et
en france représente à peu près 40 sites
actifs et nous n'en sommes qu'au début
touché également ce site de ventes aux
enchères en ligne
son conseil aux clients ne jamais donner
ses coordonnées par email il faut
vraiment être très fin du mois continuer
à développer à informer les internautes
sur le fait que jamais nous ne leur
donnerons de communiquer leurs
coordonnées par e-mail une affaire a
déjà été jugé en france l'escroc était
un étudiant en informatique
mais dans la plupart des cas c'est la
criminalité organisée qui se cache
derrière